The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: --play
with each other.
We did the standard model
as an effective field
theory, higher
dimension operators
in the standard model.
And then we started talking
about taking the standard model
as a theory one and
removing things from it,
in particular
constructing what's
called the weak Hamiltonian
by removing the top W, Z,
and Higgs from the
standard model.
And last time, we were focusing
on the anomalous dimensions
and things about
renormalization.
So we had this equation
for the weak Hamiltonian
for a particular case
of b goes to c u bar d.
That was the case
that we decided
to study rather than
the full Hamiltonian.
So there was some pre-factor.
We had two operators with Wilson
coefficients and operators.
These are four-fermion
operators.
And there was different bases.
We could write them
in the bare form,
or we could write them in
renormalized coefficient
and renormalized operator.
And then we could do it
either in the 1, 2 basis
or the plus minus basis.
So the plus minus basis is
just linear combinations
of the 1, 2.
If you're in the 1,
2 basis, then you
have this mixing matrix.
So it's a 2 by 2 matrix.
So if you're in the
plus minus basis,
then at least, at
the lowest order,
it's a simple product equation.
So plus doesn't
interfere with minus.
OK.
So that's where we got to,
and we'll just continue today.
So we have these anomalous
dimension equations
for the operators.
We can also write down
anomalous dimension equations
for the Wilson coefficients.
How do we do that?
Well, the way that we do that
is we make use of the fact
that, if we look at the first
line here, there's no mu.
So the Hamiltonian
is mu independent.
That means that the mu
dependence of the coefficient
cancels the mu dependence
of the operator.
And you can use that to
take an anomalous dimension
equation for the
operator and turn it
into one for the coefficient.
So last time, we
talked about the fact
that the normalization
of the operators
was equivalent
to-- you can think
about it two different ways.
There's renormalization of
operators, renormalization
of coefficients.
Likewise, you can think
of anomalous dimensions
is either running
the coefficients
or running the operators.
So those are equivalent things.
And the thing that
makes them equivalent
is just imposing that the
derivative with respect
to mu of the Hamiltonian is 0.
So if I use my equation up
here for anomalous dimension
of the operator, I get, with my
sign convention, a minus sign
here.
Or I had a minus sign here.
I had no minus sign here.
These things are conventions.
I picked some convention,
and I'll stick with it.
So from this
equation, we basically
have an equation that has to
be true for the coefficients
if we think of just
stripping off the operator.
So we could write it this
way, just reading it off right
from here, just putting
this guy on the other side
and then reading it off,
dropping the operator.
Or we could write
it this way if we
wanted to write
it in a way that's
more similar to this
equation up here, where
you have the anomalous dimension
matrix times the coefficient.
It's either from the
right or from the left,
and it's just a
matter of transposing.
So the anomalous dimension
for the coefficient
is determined from the
one, this one here.
If you know it,
then you immediately
know the one for the
coefficient, which
shouldn't be surprising given
that we could think of the Z
factors as being related
to renormalization factors.
Anomalous dimensions, therefore,
should also be related.
OK, so we'll solve
this equation.
It's a little bit
simpler to think about.
Although we could
have equivalently
solve the operator equation.
So how do we solve the equation?
Well, we go over to
our plus minus basis.
So take the coefficient
of either C+ or C-.
And the equation
that we need to solve
can be written as follows.
It's a simple equation.
And I can even take the C,
which is on the right-hand side,
move it over to the left,
if I write log C here.
Because the derivative of the
log is giving me a 1 over C.
If I put it back over here,
it would just multiply.
OK, so that's the analog.
This equation here is the
analog of this equation
here for the operators, but
now for the coefficients.
Obviously, if these are numbers,
there's no transpose to do.
So you have to solve this
equation simultaneously
with another
differential equation.
This is a coupled equation
because alpha also
has a differential equation.
So at lowest order, this is
the beta function equation.
And so if we want to solve,
take into account this equation
and integrate this equation,
the simple trick for doing that
is to make a change of variable.
So we use this equation here
to make a change of variable.
This is a very useful
trick because it actually
works to whatever
order in the expansion
that you might want to work.
So let me explain what the
trick is, and then I'll
explain why that is.
So we're going to change
variables in this equation
from mu to alpha.
You see we could think about
solving this equation here
by integrating, just move
this thing to the other side
and integrate.
But we'd be integrating,
in mu, a function that's
a function of alpha of mu.
So if we can switch
from mu to alpha,
then we'll be just integrating
a function of alpha.
And that's what we're going
to do using this equation.
So if I write it in general,
that's this equality here.
For any function of alpha,
I say that d mu over mu--
just rearranging this equation--
is d alpha over beta of alpha.
So I can switch the
integration d mu over mu
to d alpha over beta of alpha.
And that's exactly
what I want to do
if I want to move this
operator to the other side,
this operation.
If I work at lowest order
in the beta function,
then that's just I just
plug in this result.
So we can switch variables
from mu to alpha.
And if I had high order terms
in this equation and high order
terms in this equation, I
could use the same trick.
I just have other
integrals to do.
And the integrals are
pretty straightforward,
so this is a useful
way of proceeding.
OK.
So what does that do?
So now, let's do that.
Let's move this
over and integrate.
Well, we'll do a definite
integral from mu w up to mu.
So here, we just
have d log this.
Integrate that-- just gives
log between the limits.
And if I didn't change
variable, I would have that.
But if I make the
change variable,
then it becomes a
very simple integral.
And remember that
this guy here is also
just a number times alpha
that we worked out last time.
So this is just d
alpha over alpha.
And that's a simple
logarithmic integral.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if it matter,
but mu w should be
greater than mu, right?
IAIN STEWART: Mu w should
be greater than mu.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you're
just writing integrals
like that to avoid signs?
OK.
I have another question.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you know
that the anomalous dimensions,
including the beta function,
are only functions of alpha S
rather than [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Ah, yeah.
So I'm sneaking that in here.
So it follows from the
renormalization structure
of this effective field
theory that there's only
single logarithmic divergences.
So in the standard model,
if you're at one loop,
you only have 1 over epsilon
poles for the renormalization.
And you're renormalizing
the coupling.
The same is true of
this effective theory.
At one loop, you only have
1 over epsilon divergences.
And that implies that
your anomalous dimensions
won't depend on anything
more complicated.
We will discuss more
complicated cases in the future,
as you know.
But the structure of this
effective theory and its UV
structure, which I didn't go
into on a lot of detail about,
implies that fact.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
OK.
So do the integral.
There's some pre-factor,
which I'll call a+-.
And then I get a
log, as I mentioned.
And just for the
record, this a+-,
if I put all the factors
together and put in what this
number is, these would be
some factors like this.
And I've put in that Nc is 3.
So this alpha at mu w
and this C+ of mu w,
you should think of mu w as
the boundary condition scale.
So this is a
differential equation.
We needed a boundary
condition to solve it.
And the boundary
condition is the value
of the coefficients
at the scale uw, which
is supposed to be of order Mw.
Typically, what
that means is you
could take a common
choice, which
would be just to take it equal.
Or you could pick twice or half.
And these are the most common
choices that people pick.
So the way that you
should think of that,
this guy in the
denominator, is you
should think that he's really
a fixed order series in alpha
of mu w, something that you
would calculate order by order
and perturbation theory.
And you'd be determining
the boundary condition.
We'll talk about how you would
do that a little later today.
But for now, just think of it
as a series in alpha of mu w.
And it doesn't have
any large logarithms.
And as Elia said,
you want to think
of this mu as some small scale,
some scale that's less than uw
because you're
thinking of evolving
the operators to a scale
less than the scale
where you integrated
out the particles.
I'll draw that
picture in a second.
So we can take the
exponential of that equation,
and then we can write C of
mu is equal to something
that we've determined.
Take the exponential.
Move this guy to the other side.
Remember the a+-
are just numbers.
We can write the solution in
this way, where we determine
this guy by thinking about
doing a matching calculation
at the high scale.
We determine it to be 1/2
already at the lowest order.
So think about
sticking in 1/2 here.
And then this factor
here is what you get
from the renormalization group.
And you can see from
this form right here
that you've summed up an
infinite number of logarithms.
It's exponential of
a number times log.
And if I were to expand that out
in alpha of some fixed scale,
there would be an infinite
series in logarithms.
OK.
So what do we want to
pick this mu to be?
Well, we're thinking about the
process mu goes to c u bar d.
If you think about
this process in nature,
the scale in the initial state
here is the b has a mass.
So you'd like to take this
scale here not at Mw, but down
at the b core mass.
So we want mu to be of order Mb.
And then you have a large
hierarchy because this
is much less than Mw--
5 g of e-ish, 80 g of e.
So our result here sums what are
called the leading logarithms,
which is denoted by LL.
And schematically, the
lowest order term was 1/2.
And if we were to expand
higher order terms
and think about what
logarithms we're talking about,
we're talking about
logarithms of Mw over Mb.
And the series, if
we were to expand it,
would look like
this schematically
without worrying about
the coefficients,
an infinite series where each
term has one alpha and one log.
So the counting
that you're doing
in this type of setup,
where we would think
of using this equation to
go down to the scale Mb,
is that you're counting
this parameter as order 1.
And you're saying,
any time I see
a log of Mw over
Mb times an alpha,
I'm not going to count
that as order alpha.
I'm going to count
that as order 1.
That's why I have to sum
up this infinite series.
So the physical picture
of what we've said here
is the following.
So the basic physical
picture would
be that there's two
scales, Mw an Mb, which
are physical scales.
You want to get rid
of the scale Mw.
You do that by going over to
this electroweak Hamiltonian.
But then you have
to renormalization
group evolve Hamiltonian down to
the scale where you want to do
physics, which is the scale Mb.
And when you do that, there's
some choice in the matter.
And we've been careful to
parameterize that choice.
We said that you
pick a scale that's
of order Mw, which
we called mu w.
And then we said, you
pick another scale
that's of order Mb,
which we called mu.
And you actually do the
renormalization group
between these two.
You could pick Mw and
mu equal exactly Mb.
That would be another
simpler story.
But it is actually
important that,
once you go beyond
the lowest order,
to keep track of the fact
that you have this freedom.
And that's why I've
kept track over here.
So what that means is
that, in terms of counting,
you've counted this,
but logs of mu or Mw
were counted as order 1.
And then down here,
logs of mu over B
are counted as order 1 numbers.
It could be 0, but 0 is
order 1, not enhanced
such that they would compensate
for a factor of alpha.
And this is the renormalization
group evolution or the running
that sums up these logarithms
here, which are the large logs.
And that's pretty simple.
It just gave this factor.
And that's pretty common
in QCD to get factors
like that, alpha at
one scale over alpha
at another scale
raised to a power.
That's a very common thing to
get from renormalization group
evolution.
OK, any questions so far?
How many people have
done the calculation
of the anomalous dimension
for four-fermion operators
in some other course?
It's a common problem.
Nobody?
All right.
That means you'll
see it on a homework.
So let's come back
here and think
about what the general
structure of what we've done is.
And I'll put back indices.
So you can think about taking
the solution that we have
at the top of the board
here and generalizing it
to a form that would be
valid at higher orders.
And basically, it says that
the coefficient at one scale
is connected to the
coefficient at another scale
times some evolution factor.
In this case, the
evolution factor
is just the ratio of
these alphas to a power.
It could be some more
complicated function
at higher orders.
And it could even be a matrix.
That's why I've
given it indices.
So we can put our
results back together
using this higher order
form, so that they're
generally true,
into our Hamiltonian
and see what we've achieved.
And let me call this scale
that I was calling mu a minute
ago mu b just to remind you
that it's a scale of order Mb.
So previously, we had the
coefficient and the operator
at the same scale.
But now, using this equation,
I can move the coefficient
to a different scale.
And so let me think of
sticking this equation in.
And then I have mu w.
I've called mu equals mu b.
So now, this is mu w mu b.
So this here is the
coefficient Ci at mu b,
but I find it useful
to write it out.
So the thing in square
brackets is Ci mu b,
but I write it out using
the renormalization group
equation that way.
And this tells you how
you're doing the calculation.
This is a fixed
order calculation.
This comes from
anomalous dimensions
and gives you the evolution.
And then you have operators
involving the B quark
that you would calculate
matrix elements of at mu
b of order Mb.
And there's no dependence at all
in those operators on the scale
Mw.
All the Mw's are in
the pre-factors here.
You've taken that into account.
You've calculated it.
OK, so that's how this
organizes the physics
of the different scales.
So you could ask,
if I had this story,
how would I go to higher orders?
And we will have some
discussion of what
goes on at higher orders because
there are some things that
happen at higher orders that
you don't see at leading order.
And they're actually
important physical things,
so important things
to know about and keep
track of if you ever want
to use things like this.
So let's talk a little
bit about what it
takes to go to higher orders.
So let's just first
think about what
it would look like if we
went to higher orders.
Well, leading order was a series
that I could schematically say
is alpha times large logs.
And I summed them all up, and
I called that leading log.
When I go to higher
orders, I am going
to continue to get series, but
I got extra factors of alpha.
So something that you call
Next to Leading Log, or NLL,
is the same type of thing, a
different series than that 1
times an extra factor of alpha.
So it's down compared
to this by alpha S.
And then you keep going.
This is the general structure
of the renormalization group
improved perturbation theory.
Just keep adding Ns and
keep adding alphas, always
summing up some series which
changes from order to order.
And that summation
of that series
is determined by
determining higher order
anomalous dimensions.
So this kind of thing is called
renormalization group improved
perturbation theory.
Every time you take alpha S
and you take it at some scale,
you're already doing
renormalization group
improved perturbation theory.
It's just that, once
you have theories
that have other things that run
and have anomalous dimensions,
then it can be more complicated
than just simply picking alpha
S at the appropriate scale.
Here, in this theory, we
have these coefficients.
We have to run them.
Then we have to pick them
at the appropriate scale.
And that's what we're
doing by solving
these renormalization
group equations.
OK.
So what do we need to do?
We determined this.
I showed you what you
needed to do to get that.
What would we need to do to get
the next term in the series?
How much would we
have to compute?
Well, we just have to
go to one higher order
in the perturbation theory.
So let's make a
little table of what
it takes to get leading
log, next leading log.
Maybe we'll even
add one more term.
So there's two parts
to the calculation.
There's the boundary
condition, and then there's
the differential equation, which
is the anomalous dimension.
At leading log, we had
tree level matching.
We determined the C plus
and minus where 1/2.
C1 and C2 were 1 and 0.
And we just needed the one
loop anomalous dimension.
And then we just keep
going in this pattern.
So next leading log, we
need to match it one loop.
And we would need the
two-loop anomalous dimension
and et cetera.
So the order in which
you need the running
is one higher order than what
you need for the matching.
That's the rule.
And given those
ingredients, we would
be able to determine exactly
these series here, OK?
So there's some things
that happen at this order
that aren't really apparent
yet at leading log,
and so I want to talk a
little bit about that.
Before we get there, let me
add one other little note.
This operator O2, we didn't see
it when we thought originally
about matching.
It had Wilson coefficient
that was 0 at tree level.
So at leading order, you
could say that this Wilson
coefficient is 0.
But at leading log, it's not 0.
So I have these two different
types of perturbation theory.
Just order by order
and alpha or doing
renormalization
group improvement,
you get different results.
And that's because you've
included some higher order
terms by using the
renormalization group improved
version.
But you can argue, if alpha
times the large log is order 1,
then this is the right type
of perturbation theory to do.
So if you think about it as
a picture where this is mu,
this is Mw, this is Mb, then
you have two coefficients, C1
and C2.
We call them C+ and C-,
but they're just related.
And the results that we
derived at leading order
were that, for C1, it started
at 1 at the high scale,
basically, if we
mu w equal to Mw.
And it would evolve,
actually, this direction
if we put in all the signs that
came out of our calculations.
And for C2, it starts at 0 here,
and then it evolves this way
to a negative value.
[INAUDIBLE]
So roughly putting
in some numbers,
the kind of thing that
we would get is this.
So a coefficient which was 0 all
of a sudden becomes minus 0.3
and becomes something that
you have to keep track of.
That's at leading log.
Obviously, when you
go to higher orders,
those numbers will be
perturbatively improved.
OK.
So is the physical picture
here clear of what's happening
with these operators?
So what is the application?
Since we spent all this
time deriving these results,
we should have some
applications in mind.
So for b to c u bar d, if you
ask about what process that
gives, well, one
process that it gives
is just a B to D pi transition.
B bar is built over u bar b.
And this guy is u bar c.
And the pi is the u bar d.
So we can think of the reason
we're studying this is maybe
we want to calculate B of D pi.
So if we wanted to
calculate B of D pi,
we take matrix elements
involving our Hamiltonian
with a B [INAUDIBLE] in the
in state and a D pi in the out
state.
And if we just use the
original Hamiltonian
that we wrote down with
the renormalization group
improvement, then
we would have that.
That's with that renormalization
group improvement.
So this is at mu equals Mw.
And the problem
with this formula
is that this matrix
element has large logs.
It depends on Mw.
It also depends on Mb.
And if it's something
we can't calculate,
then that's kind of bad news.
In particular, having
large logs like that
would also make it hard
to calculate something
like this on the lattice.
So it's not just a--
It's really a problem.
If you have multiple
scales tied together,
it just makes the
calculations harder.
It's also a problem for
dimensional analysis.
Because if you have
large logs, that
means you've got large numbers.
And something that you
thought was of a certain size
might be bigger or smaller.
So what we do is, instead, we
work in the renormalization
group improved version where we
take this down at the scale Mb.
So this guy includes the
renormalization group
evolution.
We use our results over there.
And then we've got the
operators at the scale Mb,
and there's no large logs.
OK, so you'd want to
calculate something
like this on the lattice
or some other way.
There's other ways of doing it.
And we'll talk about other
ways of doing it later on.
But so far, we've
separated out the scale Mw
into this coefficient
that's evaluated
at the scale of mu equals Mb.
OK.
So the one way of
thinking about this
is, if you want to do
physics at the scale Mb,
the right couplings to use in
your theory are these ones.
Forget about what's going
on at the high scale.
You have to determine
the low energy
couplings that are appropriate
to the theory you're
dealing with.
And those are the C's at Mb, OK?
All right.
OK.
So now, I want to come back
to this question of thinking
about the next leading log.
And I'm going to do
that by going back
to our comparison of full
theory to effective theory.
We'll do a comparison of
results in the full theory
and results in the
effective theory.
And I'll show you how, by
making that comparison,
we can determine the ingredients
that we need for this one loop
matching here.
So we'll focus on this.
So we already renormalized
the effective theory.
So we can compare the
renormalized effective theory
and full theory.
And that's the right
way to proceed.
So in our parlance of
theory one and theory two,
the effective theory
would be theory two.
We have to think about the full
theory, which in our parlance
would be theory one,
the full theory being
the standard model here.
We have to think about
renormalizing that theory.
But in the standard
model, our calculation
involves conserved currents.
These are just a weak currents.
And so there's actually
no extra UV divergences
associated to those currents.
We just have coupling
renormalization.
And one way of saying
this is that what happens
is that the vertex
in the wave function
graphs, the UV
divergences cancel
or the conserved current.
So the result for
the full theory
will be some result that
is independent of having--
it doesn't have any
ultraviolet divergences.
And like the effective
theory, where
you had to carry out a
renormalization of operators
in that theory, for
the full theory,
coupling renormalization
is all there is.
So let's draw the
full theory graphs.
Gluons should be green.
Maybe my w should be pink.
Six permutations--
and then there's also
wave function normalization.
OK.
So if you want to do the
full theory calculation,
these are the
graphs you compute.
It's triangles as
well as box integrals.
It's actually a much
harder calculation
than in the effective theory.
And I'm not going to
do the calculation,
but I'll tell you what
the results look like.
So let's start by
thinking about the logs.
And then we'll talk
about the constants that
are under the logs as well.
So if we look at
this calculation,
it has the following form.
So there's S1, which
was some spinners.
We defined it in
an earlier lecture.
There's something
involving a log,
and it has a p squared. p
squared was the off-shellness
associated to these guys.
And we regulated the infrared
divergences with p squared.
So p squared not equal to
0 regulates IR divergences.
And there are IR divergences
in these diagrams.
Even though I said
they are UV finite,
they're not finite
in the infrared.
And that's what leads to
these logs of p squared.
OK.
Now, I didn't write everything.
I only wrote the pieces
proportional to S1.
There's pieces proportional
to the other spinner, S2.
And there's mod log terms.
And they're all
hiding in the dots.
So let's compare this result
to a similar expression
in the effective
theory that we just
set the coefficients to the
values at the high scale.
So then we have 1
for the coefficient
times the one-loop
matrix element of O1,
which we wrote down earlier.
And it looks kind of similar to
this, but not exactly the same.
It's very similar, but
not precisely the same.
A similar statement applies
to these guys over here, OK?
So the difference is
really that, instead
of Mw squared in this
log, we have a mu squared.
That's really the only
difference for these terms.
With constant terms, the
non-logarithmic terms
here and here won't agree.
And we'll talk about
those things in a minute.
So what do we learn by thinking
about the physics of these two
equations?
Well, one comment is
the comment I already
said, that the effective theory
computation for this line
here is much, much
easier than this one.
So one reason to use
effective field theory
is just that it makes
computations easier.
And the reason it makes
computations easier
is because you're
basically dealing
with one scale at a time.
And whenever you have integrals
involving only one scale,
that's always much easier
than having multiple scales.
But if you want to encode all
the physics of the full theory,
you'll still have to do that
calculation at some point
as well.
Although you may be able to do
it in a simpler configuration
to get off the
information that you need.
Furthermore, if you really
only cared about the logs,
then all you really need
is the 1 over epsilon term.
And that's even easier than
the full triangle diagrams.
So to compute the
anomalous dimensions,
you just have to
keep the divergences.
And you can throw away
all the finite pieces.
And that's even easier.
So you can organize things by
thinking about doing the easier
calculations first.
That's what people do.
They calculate
anomalous dimensions
before they calculate matching
because it's just easier.
And it's also the thing you
need for the leading log result.
You don't need the matching at
one loop for the leading log
result. So there's a
conservation of ease
and what you need.
These two things play
nicely with each other.
Second point-- in
the effective theory,
you're supposed to think
that Mw goes to infinity.
And that's why this thing
doesn't know about Mw.
So how could it
possibly get an Mw?
And so what happens is that
Mw gets replaced by the cut
off, which is mu here.
Another point that we can
make about this-- if you
look at the logs
of minus p squared,
they're all the same
between the two equations.
That's actually
important because what
that means is that the infrared
structure of the two theories
agree.
The logs of p squared are
the infrared divergences.
They agree between the higher
theory and the lower theory.
And they have to agree.
What this tells you about
the effective theory
is that you're doing
something right.
In particular, it tells you
that your effective theory has
the right degrees of freedom.
That's almost trivial
in this example.
What other degrees of freedom
could we possibly think
that would be missing?
But in more
complicated examples--
and we will deal with at
least one such example later
in the course--
it's not so trivial to see
that these things match up.
And people have discovered
new degrees of freedom
by doing matching
computations like this.
They said, oh, this is a
relevant degree of freedom.
And it's needed.
Because if I do a
one-loop calculation,
I need it to get the
infrared divergences right.
So this can really teach you
about the effective theory,
doing a matching
computation, teach you
about the physics of
the effective theory.
So if you made a mistake,
this would be a place
where you'd catch yourself.
Now, that you've analyzed
fully what the differences are,
you can subtract them.
You take the difference of
the renormalized calculations.
And that is what gives
you one-loop matching.
Just like we compared
tree level calculations
to get tree level matching, we
compare one-loop calculations
to get one-loop matching.
So [INAUDIBLE] we do that.
At tree level, if we're just
looking at the S1 pieces,
we have these two terms.
And then at one-loop--
let me use this notation.
This is the full A.
So it has a tree level
piece and one-loop piece.
Then we take the piece of
the C1 that's at one loop.
And we take the matrix
element of the operator,
evaluate it order alpha.
And then there's C2 terms.
Let me just put dots.
OK, so there's two ways
that I can get an alpha.
There's an order
alpha coefficient.
That's what I want to know,
what you want to determine.
And then there's an order
alpha matrix element.
So by subtracting, putting
this guy on the left-hand side,
I get the value of C1 of 1.
So we use this equation
to determine this.
And the story would be similar
if I kept all the C2 terms.
So the matching,
i.e. the difference
of the full and effective
theory and calculations,
determines that
coefficient for you.
So the notation
here is that we'd
write the full coefficient as 1
plus C1 plus higher order terms
where this is order alpha.
That's the notation I'm using.
So let's do that for the logs.
It's pretty simple.
These things here
are just cancel.
And this one we can
just subtract them.
The p squareds will cancel.
And we'll get a log of my
squared over Mw squared.
So just focusing on those
terms that we have in S1--
and rearranging the
equation in the way
I said and then plugging in
the values for the things that
don't cancel.
So the terms that were
slightly different--
and dropping the S1.
CF is 4/3.
It's Casimir of the fundamental.
We see that, since we've
only kept the log terms, what
we find is the one-loop
correction in this guy that's
got a logarithm.
but it'd also be a term here
that's a number times alpha.
But we haven't kept
those terms in what
I've written on the board.
So the way that you
should think about this
is that we've got these
Wilson coefficients that
depend on the scale Mw.
And what the matching is doing,
it's taking the full theory.
And it's dividing it into
large momentum pieces
times small momentum pieces.
So the large momentum
pieces are in C. Small
momentum pieces are in the
matrix element of the operator.
And this statement, we see an
explicit realization of it.
The full theory knows about high
scale Mw's and the p squared.
And we can write this
as a split like this.
The effective theory knows about
p squared, doesn't know about
Mw squared.
The Wilson coefficient
knows about Mw squared,
doesn't know about p squared.
The additional thing
that they both know about
is the scale mu.
And that's providing
a cutoff for where
you split between large
momentum and small momentum
p squared was the small scale.
Now, if you look
at this equation,
you may wonder for a minute.
Why is it additive?
Up here, I just said times.
And then immediately
below times,
I wrote something that was a
sum, seemed a little weird.
That's just because, if you take
something that includes the 1,
then the product becomes a sum.
So if I write it this way, I
can write it in product form
if I include the one tree level.
So it really is a product.
It's just that, if you look
at the order alpha pieces,
it breaks into the sum
where we can nicely see how
things are combining together.
But really it has this
product structure,
and there's non-trivial
relations between these two
series that make it
all work out even when
you go to higher orders.
So if I expand that
to order alpha,
look at the order
alpha coefficient.
I get this equation back again.
And this is how you would
think about it in product form.
OK.
So the other thing you see
here is that order by order
in our expansion, as we
kind of already stated,
the mu dependence between
these coefficients and these
operators is exactly cancelling
because the full theory here
didn't involve that mu.
That's another little piece
of information that we get
or that we knew, but
we see explicitly
from looking at this.
So I think, if I'm
counting right,
this is comment number five.
Was there a question?
So not surprisingly,
the cut off dependence
cancels in the product
of C of mu O of mu
because the cut off
is what we introduced
to split up the physics
in these two things.
Now, if you look at that
in a little more detail,
it's only mu independent of the
order in perturbation theory
that you're working.
If you've worked at a fixed
order in some expansion,
then you shouldn't be surprised
that everything you've derived
is only true at that order.
So if you stopped
at one loop, then
it's mu independent
at order alpha S.
What that technically
means is that terms that
are alpha S mu log mu cancel.
The log mu here cancels, but
there's mu dependence also
here.
And that mu dependence
in the alpha
is something that would
be related to terms
that are alpha squared log mu.
And that cancels
at higher order.
So some of the mu
dependents cancel.
Some of the mu dependents
doesn't cancel.
And people actually use the fact
that some of the mu dependence
doesn't cancel as getting a
handle on the higher order
terms.
It's doing a kind of
theory uncertainty.
If we just think
about the logarithms,
then actually the one-loop
results in the full theory
has actually less information.
And the reason is that, if
you wanted to get higher order
terms in this leading log
series that we talked about,
if you wanted to derive
those from the full theory
point of view, you'd have to
do a two-loop computation.
So if you wanted to get alpha
squared log squared of Mw
squared over minus p
squared, then you'd
have to look at
diagrams, two gluons.
On the full theory
point of view,
that's what you'd have to
do to find those terms.
From the effective
theory point of view,
all you have to do
to find those terms
is renormalize the
effective theory properly.
And then you get those terms.
So we just needed the
one-loop anomalous dimension.
So in that sense,
the effective theory,
because of the
renormalization properties
of the effective
theory, know something
that the full theory
doesn't know so easily.
And that kind of shows
you the advantage
of taking something that's
a constant, Mw squared,
and turning it into a scale.
Because by turning
it into a scale,
you have the whole power of
the renormalization group
at your disposal to
predict higher order
things, like the higher
order coefficients.
And that's one way
of phrasing what
the example is of
splitting scales
and going to the
effective theory.
So the final thing that
I want to talk about here
has to do with the fact that--
well, actually, there's two more
things I want to talk about,
but let me make the
final comment here.
So the final comment I
want to make in my list,
which is number seven, has
to do with scheme dependence.
So scheme dependence
means that we
pick the renormalization
scheme MS bar.
And we could have
done the calculation
in a different
renormalization scheme.
And we should ask what
depends on that choice.
You may know, if you've taken
a course on the beta function
or if you've taken QFD3,
that the beta function of QCD
is scheme independent
for the first two orders.
The analog of that
statement here
is that the one-loop anomalous
dimension for our operators
is scheme independent.
It doesn't depend on which mass
independent scheme you pick.
So in the class of mass
independence schemes,
the result is what we derived.
We'll come back and study
that in a little more detail.
OK, so let's go back now
and establish some notation
where we actually just
put the constants back in.
And again, I'm not
going to write numbers.
I'll just give them names.
And we'll track what
happens to them.
So let's think about the
full one-loop matching
and how we get the next
leading log result.
And really what I want to
focus on, or at least one thing
I want to focus on, is
the scheme dependence.
Because the coefficients, once
you get to next leading log,
are totally scheme dependent.
So you can ask,
what physical sense
do they make if they're
scheme dependent?
Well, it turns out that the
matrix elements are also
scheme dependent.
And the anomalous dimensions
are scheme dependent.
So basically, everything
is scheme dependent.
And when we put it all
together, we get a scheme
independent result. So
you might think, well,
if we can get scheme
dependent results,
we should just stop
because maybe we can't
understand what's going on.
But C of mu times O of mu is
independent of the scheme.
It's a physical observable.
And physical
observables don't depend
on our definitions of things.
Nature gets to decide, not us.
So one way of
thinking about this
is that we already saw some
kind of scheme independence
in a statement that
C of mu times O of mu
is independent of mu.
But there's even a deeper
scheme independence to it
that it's independent of whether
we chose MS bar or some others
scheme.
So for the context
of this discussion,
I'm going to start dropping
all the matrix indices.
And we're not going
to write i and j
just because I want to keep
things a little bit simple.
So we'll write that the
effective theory is simply
one coefficient times the
matrix of one operator.
So let's think about,
in that context, trying
to understand where all this
scheme dependence is floating
around and how the
matching works.
So we just do the same
thing we did before.
I'm leaving off
some pre-factors,
leaving off the pre-factors.
I don't have the write
the spinners anymore
since there's only
one structure.
And let me introduce some
notation for the results.
So we had this Mw squared
over p squared type term.
And let me just focus on these
terms and not the terms that
just cancelled away.
So let me focus on the
terms that are different.
But now, I'm also going
to include the constants.
So the constants that we
get in the full theory
and the effective
theory are different.
So I'll call one of them
A and the other one B.
So I call the A the
full theory result
and the B the effective
theory result.
So you should think
of this as a number,
like 3, just some
number, same thing here.
But just to avoid
talking about numbers
and to track also where
the scheme dependence is--
like this 3 could
be 2 in one scheme
and this 4 could be 2 in one
scheme and 5 in another scheme.
In order to keep track of that,
let me call it a variable.
Let me call it B.
So then the Wilson
coefficient is just
we construct the difference.
And then we'll have
an A minus B in it.
So if you like what the
Wilson coefficient is doing,
it's compensating for the
fact that the effective theory
has the wrong value
for this constant.
It should be this.
That's what the full
theory told you it was.
So the effective theory
Wilson coefficient
has minus the effective
theory matrix element
result plus the
correct result. So this
is the thing that's correcting
the effective theory.
So it has the right constant.
And if we just take
C at Mw, then it
would simply be equal to that.
And the log would go away.
So in order to do the
renormalization group
improved perturbation
theory at next leading log,
we also need to do a
two-loop computation.
We're not going to do the
two-loop consultation,
but I'll tell you the
structure of the series
that you get if you
did that computation.
So this equation is true.
Therefore, we can write the
anomalous dimension equation
again as log C.
And the right-hand
side will be a series.
And the structure of the
series that was there
is the 0-th order term.
And then there's some
higher order terms.
And we need this guy,
the two-loop coefficient,
[INAUDIBLE] gamma 1.
Again, this is a coupled
differential equation.
And we would solve it by
using the kind of thing
that we did before.
So d mu over mu is d
alpha over beta of alpha.
And we would write
down beta to one higher
order, which I do in my notes.
But it's the same idea is
I just expand it in alpha.
And I keep not just
the coefficient beta 0,
but I also keep the
coefficient beta 1.
I want to kind of not focus
so much on the calculations,
but more the results
and the implications
of the calculations.
So do some renormalization
group evolution.
You can write the all-order
solution as an integral,
like we did before.
And if I just keep it in terms
of these all-order objects,
then it's just the ratio, which
I expand that ratio in alpha.
And if I want to do
it to second order,
I don't just keep
the first time.
I keep the second term.
So the first term
was a 1 over alpha.
So we're going to keep the
order alpha to the 0 term.
And if we use our notation
that we established before,
where we call this guy here,
we call the exponential
of this guy u, so C of u C of
mu 0, of mu w mu of mu w mu.
Then we can write the
solution of that guy
as an exponential of an integral
of d alpha gamma over beta.
So some of the steps that we
were doing at one-loop, just
like the exponentiation,
the separation,
they just all go through.
And the only thing
we do have to do
is evaluate this integral
at one higher order.
Let me take mu w equal to
Mw and then do the integral.
And what you get is
a result that we can
organize in the following way.
Try to get my arguments
in the right order.
In this particular case, the
next leading log solution
looks as follows.
Our leading log solution is
obviously buried inside it.
So we have this ratio of alphas,
something which is a number.
And then there's
these extra factors
that depend on this then j.
And I can write
the result this way
where j involves all the things
that are the higher order
ingredients.
So it involves the lowest order
anomalous dimension, but now
times beta 1.
That's like taking the leading
order anomalous dimension,
but now running the coupling
with the second order term
as well.
And then there's a term that
involves the second order
anomalous dimension.
So it encodes that information.
So this is the U. We can
combine that together
with our equation for the
C over here, or this one.
So let me keep that one.
So I take this equation,
multiply by that equation.
That gives us C of mu.
So I have to write
this lone more time.
And basically, I can group that
together with these other terms
that depend on an alpha of Mw.
OK.
So j is the anomalous
dimension piece.
A and B are the matching.
A minus B is the matching piece.
And I can write the
result this way.
So this is next
leading order matching,
which is A minus
B and next leading
log running to get the full
next leading log result.
So this is the kind of
structure that you could get.
That's what
renormalization group
improved perturbation
theory looks like when
you go to higher orders.
You basically have logs.
But then the higher
order terms, when
you expand out this
integral, are just giving you
polynomials in alpha.
So when you integrate
polynomials,
you get back polynomials.
So if you integrate
1, you get alpha.
If you integrate alpha squared,
you get alpha cubed, et cetera.
So you just get
back polynomials.
And that's why you
can write it this way.
What are the terms
in this result
that are scheme dependent?
I claim that beta 1 gamma 1--
oh, why did I-- not beta 1, B1.
B1 gamma 1 J, C, O, these
are all scheme dependent.
They depend on what
renormalization scheme
I use to define my
effective theory.
And then there's
a list of things
that are scheme independent.
So beta 0 and beta 1
are scheme independent.
I told you that gamma 0
is scheme independent.
You could think
of that like, when
you do the one-loop calculation,
the ultraviolet divergences are
always going to be the same.
You get 1 over epsilon.
And it's only the constant
that depends on your scheme.
A1 is scheme independent.
That's because A1 was the
full theory calculation.
So how could it
possibly know how
we define the effective theory?
So that's scheme independent.
And a non-trivial one is that
B1 plus J is scheme independent.
So there's scheme dependence in
B1 and scheme dependence in J,
but it cancels in exactly
the combination that's
showing up in this result.
And as I mentioned, C times
O is scheme independent
because that's related
to observables.
So I have a little proof
of that in my notes,
which, because of time,
I'm going to skip.
But I encourage you, when I post
my notes through the website,
that you take a look at
where that comes from.
So the only
non-trivial one really
is this B1 plus J being
scheme independent, OK?
I have a little proof of
that in my notes here.
OK, so let's go
back to the equation
at the top in the
middle there and see
what conclusions we can
draw once we believe this.
So if B1 plus J is
scheme independent, then
this thing that's showing up in
that term, A1 minus B minus J,
is scheme independent, as A was.
It was just a full theory thing.
And there's a cancellation
of scheme dependence
between the one-loop
anomalous dimension.
There's a cancellation
here between
the two-loop anomalous
dimension, which
we called gamma 1, and the B1.
That's where the scheme
dependence cancels.
So the scheme you pick,
you have to be consistent.
You have to keep using it.
If you do a matching
calculation or if someone else
did a matching calculation,
you want to use it.
You better figure out what
scheme they're working in.
Because if you start working
in a different scheme,
you're just making mistakes.
So this is the statement
that the matching is scheme
dependent, the anomalous
dimension scheme dependent,
but there's a cancellation
between those two.
If we look at the gamma
0 over beta 0 term,
that's scheme independent.
So that's good.
If we look over here, J
was not scheme dependent.
J is scheme dependent.
So we still have to
worry about that.
So leading log result
was scheme independent,
but we still have
scheme dependence
of this factor 1 plus alpha of
mu J over 4 pi in our C of mu.
And the thing that cancels
that scheme dependence
is the fact that the
Wilson coefficient alone
is not a physical observable.
It's really the Wilson
coefficient times the operator.
And so there is
scheme dependence
in the matrix element
of the operator.
So a matrix element of the
operator at the scale mu
is scheme dependent.
And this is at the lower
end of our integration.
So this is the final
matrix element,
like the matrix
element at the B scale.
That's a scheme dependent thing.
So if you think of
these things as numbers
that you want to determine
from data, one way of thinking
about it, those
numbers are going
to depend on what
scheme you're using.
If you extract some
numbers in one scheme
and your friend does
it in another scheme,
you could get totally
different numbers.
So you have to know what
scheme you're working in.
And you have to
combine it together
with the Wilson coefficient
in the same scheme.
If you take some numbers
from the literature
and you don't know
what scheme they're in
and you're working
at next leading log,
you have a problem.
You got to know
what the scheme is
because you have to work in
the same scheme consistently.
And that's the lesson here.
If you really want to do
this whole program that I've
talked about, which is done in
this 250 page review article--
and I'm not asking
you to read that.
If you really want to
do this whole program,
there are some subtleties.
And I should at least mention
them to you since maybe you'll
encounter the word someday.
So we've sketched the physics
and the basic stuff that
would be involved
in the analysis,
but we haven't written down
the full operator basis
with the full set
of mixing and dozens
and dozens of diagrams,
which people have done.
Mostly what you should be
thinking of this is as a user.
So I'm teaching you
the things that you
need to be able to
use results like that.
In an effective
theory, if you're
using a higher order
result, you have
to worry about scheme dependent.
So what are the subtleties?
Well, one of them is
that there's gamma 5s.
This theory is chiral.
And gamma 5 is inherently
four-dimensional.
And you have to
worry about that.
And you have to create
that carefully in dim reg.
And when people originally
did these calculations,
that caused some confusion.
Be careful enough.
Obviously, dim reg is a powerful
way of doing the calculation,
but you do have to be
careful about gamma 5.
And there's another
thing you have
to be careful about in dim reg.
And that's something that are
called evanescent operators.
You see, part of our
arguments, and originally
when we were writing down
the basis of operators
for our calculation,
were actually
inherently four-dimensional.
When we wrote down
the operators,
we said we effectively used that
these Dirac structures, which
are 16 of them, we used
completeness over those 16.
And the problem is
that, in d dimensions,
that's not a complete set.
And any opinions
that are outside that
set that are additional
operators that you
need in d dimensions are
called evanescent operators.
So they involve
Dirac structures that
vanish as epsilon goes to 0,
but are technically needed
to get some calculations right.
OK, so those are
two subtle things
to be aware of in
the full calculation.
And I think we'll
stop there for today.
And we'll do something
different next time.
So homework is due next Tuesday.
And as I said in my
original handout,
you should talk to each
other about the homework.
That's how you learn.